c'est un moyen supplémentaire de se
faire entendre
cette fois ci il s'agit de bloquer les
quatre accès delà des halles la
direction de l'environnement de
l'aménagement et du logement
les marins pêcheurs sont ici depuis 6h
du matin ça fait trois ans que ça dure
il faut il faut il faut le dragage du
port total en un secteur économique
invoquée la paix chez les matches on
peut pas travailler convenablement les
collègues est obligé de laver à 10
heures du soir et et mettre le bateau
plus loin du port pour aller c'est une
journée le matin ils arrivent ils sont
obligés de s'endetter 77 marins pêcheurs
du vauclin connaissent les mêmes
difficultés
aujourd'hui ils sont soutenus par les
membres de la soupe ahmar dans un
dossier traité à la fois par la ctm et
par là des halles
la délégation d'une trentaine de
personnes engage donc la discussion avec
le directeur
aujourd'hui ce que nous souhaitons c'est
avoir des réponses claires nettes avec
vous et pourquoi cette autorisation ne
sont pas assez c'est ce que nous sommes
devenus aujourd'hui vont demander
clairement pacifiquement combien de fois
avez vous demandé un rendez-vous
ce n'était pas à nous de vous demander
de rendez vous alors je vous explique
l'eau explique on n'avait pas trouvé
l'argent dû parce que vous travaillez
vous êtes censés travailler avec la ctm
d'accord pas avec nous vous êtes là pour
pouvoir nous donner les moyens de
travailler correctement
il s'agit dès lors de commencer une
négociation les modalités prennent du
temps
une des conditions à la présence d'un
élu de la ctm ce sera louis boutrin
autre condition que les barrières
restent closes pendant toute la durée de
la réunion
le personnel de la des halles est invité
à rentrer chez lui les négociations
commencent elle dure près de deux heures
nous sommes dans des procédures
administratives qui sont langues
nécessité pas la loi sur l'eau et qui
font qu'aujourd'hui ces travaux sont
soumis à des autorisations avec un laps
de temps long dû à une enquête publique
devant l'urgence économique et sociale
des marins pêcheurs
il a bien fallu obteniez en delà des
halles que les travaux puissent
commencer dans les meilleurs délais pour
cela il est 19 et sert d'une part de les
définir techniquement une première phase
d'urgence qui permettent rapidement aux
pêcheurs de pouvoir entrer et sortir du
port et deuxièmement effectivement gérer
les autorisations administratives
nous sommes très satisfaits cette
déclaration en fait elle sera transmise
aux préfets bien entendu une fois
réponse retour à la cité m et à partir
de là c'est m
comment ces travaux avec cette
autorisation des travaux de dragage
devraient commencer rapidement dès la
semaine prochaine